memory it can be both a blessing and a
curse you'll always remember that
beautiful moment when you and your
family walked across golden sands by the
sea on your favorite childhood vacation
your first kiss the time you discovered
your favorite movie tv show or book but
you'll always remember the time you said
you too when the movie theater usher
told you to enjoy the film or when you
first got your heart broken or the first
time you lost a friend or family member
and realized someday that others would
be mourning you or that time a giant
unkillable lizard tried to eat you alive
that's why the scp foundation has
amnestics the course of miracle drugs
that erase memories whether they're
synthetic or taken from a giant god like
eel miles under the sea amnestics are
the way the foundation erases things
that are better not remembered but what
would you like to forget we put that
question out to the wonderful fans of
scp-explained and you delivered telling
us all about the anomalies or anomalous
situations that are so horrifying you'd
want the foundation to neutralize the
living hell out of you after an
encounter so let's jump right in and see
what's better off stricken from our
mental records random user said for me
it would be scp-1733
why you may ask well the overall thought
of being trapped inside of a repeating
cycle where you eventually break into
insanity is scary to think about i'd get
my memory wiped any day of the week and
we are off to a strong existentially
horrifying start unless you're a super
fan of the boston celtics and the miami
heat being trapped in an endlessly
recursive tape of the 2010 nba season
opener would be a memory you'd want to
be erased but man that dunk from
robertson
an excellent play biotic ninja said
there's a lot i would voluntarily use
amnestics for even without encountering
scps what makes you think i would have
the mental willpower to resist taking a
few if i so much encountered such a
horrid thing we appreciate your honesty
and to be fair how do we know that you
haven't used amnestics already you could
have used it so many times to delete so
many unpleasant experiences how many
gaps black holes exist in your
recollections have you ever gone
somewhere new and gotten that nagging
sense you've been there before perhaps
you have just be sure to like this video
and leave a comment saying don't forget
i was here before in case you delete
this memory too
william clark said honestly i wish i
could take amnestics after just watching
this channel's well-executed depiction
of the red reality and then reading
comments that elaborated on some of the
more graphic details well that's
incredibly kind of you and we're equally
disturbed by the nightmarish nature of
scp-3001
the place where dr scranton has been
trapped for uncountable years losing his
body and mind sadly for scranton himself
there's no way we can ever get in there
to give him some amnestics himself but
we're sure he appreciates the sentiment
false atlas said definitely the bone
hive and the flesh that hates i already
hate bugs and disease last thing i need
for my mental health is to know those
are running around somewhere while
amnestics will solve a secondary
encounter with the bone hive earwigs or
the flesh that hates we're sad to tell
you that if you are the victim of either
of these anomalies no amount of
amnestics will soften the swirling void
of horror your life will soon become
though it might be funny to see a
horrific flesh monster stumbling around
and wondering where it left its car keys
true void chaos said scp-1762
that was one of the few scps that
brought me to tears and despite never
having met them i really miss those
dragons oh thanks for reminding us about
that one true void chaos
oh now we're feeling sad again too oh
god where's the amnestics
keep it together sarah james cena sarah
said i feel like i'd use those if i ever
participated with the desire camera i
don't think i have any dark secret
desires or that i'm evil or anything
like that although the possibility of
being shown my inner shadow has crossed
my mind i worry that seeing my true
desire might make me too narrow-minded
i'm sorry to tell you this sarah but
we've already played out this scenario
we took a photo of you with a desire
camera and you were so utterly disturbed
by the horrifying nature of your true
desire you immediately requested
amnestics but we still know what you
want and we're considering drafting a
restraining order frostking said the
yule man is one of those scps that has
given me chills to even think about if
it was real i might have to choose
ignorance on this one boys now this is a
dangerous one after all when the winter
months draw in and you're settling down
to enjoy the christmas season you might
notice strange noises in your attic
funny smells coming from outside your
house darting shadows on the yard the
feeling that you're being watched maybe
you'll just try to push those feelings
down and enjoy the holiday because you
don't know about the danger lurking
until it's too late ross albatross said
i'd want to forget about the bowl of
soup from dad the emotional triggers i
personally have as someone who lost
their father as a kid run deep we're
incredibly sorry to hear that ross and
we hope that you're able to find peace
or something close to it someday take it
from someone who also lost their dad at
a young age losing someone is never easy
and we hope you have friends and family
in your life there to support you jay
lego ninjago said the maybe they're
monsters their idea even gives me chills
monsters that can harm you yet you are
the only one able to see them also
scp-2508 a house you can't leave until
you die that has happened to many
foundation workers including 05-7 the
idea of being trapped there forever in a
place without any human contact just
creeps me out both are indeed extremely
disturbing concepts and could be things
you're eager to forget but sometimes
it's best to keep those frightening
memories for your own safety to quote
rafiki the past can hurt but you can
either run from it
okay or learn from it that was close
pseudo spy said while i feel like many
people will go with better known scps i
would have to go with scp-1981
seeing that tape would be a scary thing
to have to remember and personally i
would want to rid of it as quickly as
possible interestingly the aides of
ronald reagan himself also thought it
was best to give him amnestics after
seeing the ronald reagan cut up while
talking tape but because they didn't
give him the proper amount it wound up
destroying his mind so yeah we suppose
the moral of this story is to use
amnestics responsibly juan pereira said
as much as i love 682 as a fictional
monster the mere idea of a life-hating
violent hyper-adaptable and unkillable
atrocity would just be too much to bear
if it makes you feel any better given
how much he hates everyone
scp-682 would probably take an amnestic
to forget you as well max powers the
name you love to touch said i think just
watching what happens to the d-class on
a daily basis would make me want to
forget so many of those deaths would be
very traumatic to watch that is
incredibly true despite the fact that
many of the d-classes are themselves
violent criminals the way the foundation
treats them is undeniably inhumane and
horrific while it's easier to make a
greater good argument about all their
terrible fates as an empathetic human
being it can't be easy to watch all this
play out again and again
kingme131 said i'd probably go with
something like the sarkist cultists if i
were to encounter them i'd probably be
close to death because i love our
evolution and growth with tech and those
guys would probably do all sorts of
twisted things to me before the scp
foundation can stop it or anything
involving the children of the scarlet
king for similar reasons an interesting
thought sometimes encountering groups of
interests can be even more frightening
than encountering the anomalies
themselves sarcasts will twist your body
into the most nightmarish configurations
imaginable and the children of the
scarlet king might use dark rituals to
impregnate you with more of their dark
deities progeny so uh yeah both of these
call for some sweet sweet amnestics jean
g said i feel like i wouldn't really
ever submit myself to amnestics i have a
really morbid curiosity that makes it so
the more awful a thing i see the more i
want to understand it so yeah an mtf
member is probably going to have to
stick me or else i'd become a paranoid
lunatic trying to figure out how
anomalies work once again we appreciate
the honesty and self-awareness it's very
possible the foundation would somehow
trick you into undergoing amnestic
treatments so your investigations don't
become a thorn in their side and feeling
that they might just do things the
old-fashioned way and send an mtf hit
squad to silence you permanently yeet
year said i feel as if having an
encounter with scp-087
since the only three documented cases
have left the class-d prisoners in a
state of shock or never to be heard of
again another very wise choice
scp-087 and more specifically the entity
hiding within this bottomless staircase
leaves even its surviving victims in a
state of permanent catatonia hopefully
amnestic treatment would allow you to
regain your faculties and live something
resembling a normal life afterwards
richard womack said 096 i'm curious if
the application of amnestics in a timely
manner would quell its murderous rage
the scp foundation has been hoping to
find this one out for some time now
actually if you have scp-096 coming
after you then you may as well want to
take an amnestic if it works awesome if
not at least you'll spend a few minutes
in a state of sweet blissful ignorance
before being torn apart joaquin palisio
said for me the panacea scp mostly so
that the way i don't live with the guilt
of knowing that there is a way to
prevent death from illness or injury
even if there is no non-anomalous cure
in short if i knew about the panacea i
would go mad trying to figure out a way
to obtain it now this is an interesting
one so many people are sadly suffering
from diseases with no non-anomalous cure
and if the panacea was ever made public
it would surely become a kind of
eldorado for many suffering or wishing
to profiteer from it wars would be
started people would turn on each other
the hunt would be endless and
all-consuming perhaps it would be better
to forget than to taunt us with false
hope rahma shifa said scp-4975
i'm definitely going to need amnestics
after hearing about that absolute
terrible excuse for an scp it's just so
disturbing if you don't know what
scp-4975
is then save yourself the trouble don't
go searching about scp-4975
you'll regret it don't say i didn't warn
you well personally we don't think
there's that much to worry wait does
anyone else hear that huh i don't
remember if i brought a clock in here
must be a side effect of the amnestics
discord nation said
scp-023 the black shuck is one that
comes to mind maybe the amnestics can
cancel out the anomalous effects there's
only so far you can try to outrun fate
if you look into the eyes of the black
shuck either you or a family member of
yours is doomed to die you can make
yourself forget if it would bring you
some comfort but it would happen all the
same han guy said i'd say
scp-106 if by some miracle i survived
his pocket dimension relatively unharmed
if you did buy some miracle managed to
survive being trapped in
scp-106's horrific pocket dimension it's
unsurprising that you'd need some
amnestic therapy though leave you
wondering why you've got all those scars
and missing limbs and missing eyes and
missing teeth the old man certainly
leaves his mark on his
friends
norbis said i'd probably take amnestics
from seeing scp-2030
which i think is laugh is fun it just
has so many disturbing episodes that
would make me want to forget it what
that's ridiculous why would you ever
want to forget any classic episodes of
life is fun that show is hilarious
especially the mark with thatcher
episode some people just have no sense
of humor dark mega 5 said that one fish
that can hunt you from any body of water
if you know about it can't get hunted if
i forget about it scp-1128
also known as the aquatic horror is the
one thing more likely to give you
hydrophobia than contracting rabies and
amnestics is believed to be one of the
few ways you might be able to escape its
jaws of death still you probably won't
want to spend some time at the local
pool any time soon gamingwolf zj said if
i survived the encounter i'd definitely
give myself amnestics if i encountered
scp-3166
the idea of getting attacked by a guy
dressed up as an overly obese ginger cat
while grabbing rotten lasagna from its
gullet just to shove it into my own is
an image i would definitely use scp
foundation certified brain bleach for
look gaming wolf i get that almost being
force fed human flesh lasagna until you
die by a mutant commercialized
homunculus of a popular comic strip
character is a traumatic experience that
will leave you shaken up but is that any
excuse to fat shame garfield come on now
let's stay civil here 8ballgaming said
if i saw someone being forced through
scp-957's chest cavity then i would
literally become a class-d to unsee it
suit yourself buddy i actually think
it's an extremely entertaining sight
to each their own i suppose loot pad 67
said being in 3008 it's such a
terrifying thought that i would much
prefer leaving it to my fantasy being
trapped in the infinite ikea is a truly
terrifying thought and one you might
want to forget after escaping that being
said being trapped in a regular ikea is
also pretty terrifying you can really
lose a whole saturday trying to find a
new desk in that garish swedish flat
pack hellscape can i uh get some of
those amnestics thank you daniel justice
said the living legos so that way every
time i see them it will be as if it's my
first time seeing them and always make
me happy well that's certainly a
delightful notion we appreciate you
giving us this wholesome suggestion in
amongst the rest of the horrifying
trauma daniel it's very much appreciated
we'll give you a few doses of amnestics
as a thank you gift izzy stardust said
not much in scp but a certain procedure
we don't talk about thankfully it is
actually standard procedure to be given
amnestics after performing procedure 110
montauk to preserve its high level of
secrecy but it does have its downsides
for example you forget what chapter you
were up to in the storybook
nick t wolfe discusses said i would take
it if i met clef that guy sounds like no
fun with the odd way he is i think he
might be an unknown scp sadly we don't
believe that dr clef is anomalous he's
actually just a jerk we still wouldn't
blame you for wanting to take some
amnestics after meeting him though grand
worm said well to be honest i would use
it after watching a good movie or show
to watch it again the same goes for
books that's a fascinating approach for
what it's worth there are a lot of
wonderful movies shows and books out
there and a lot of wonderful youtube
videos here on scp explained you might
be limiting your scope by repeatedly
wiping your memory and consuming the
same pool of media again and again in
perpetuity but then again maybe you're
already stuck in that loop and any good
media you discover and enjoy in the
future is just something you've seen and
enjoyed potentially hundreds or even
thousands of times before aren't
amnestics a little creepy like that and
there you have it folks some of your
weirdest wildest and most traumatic
suggestions for all the anomalies worth
forgetting because remembering is just
too painful thank you for sending in
your thoughts and if you think we missed
any please let us know down in the
comments and keep an eye on our
community tab for more chances to take
part in the next community response
video in the meantime we'll um
i'm sorry what were we doing here again
getting so forgetful these days
might be my medication now go check out
scp-049 what actually is the pestilence
the plague doctor questions and theories
and scp-096 look at a picture of shy guy
in space the shy guy questions and
theories for more questions and answers
from the scp-explained community